très bien la zone
je reste dans mon coin je l'étais zenten
moi quand j'arrive à changer la taille
d'un tonne
un premier album pour ce jeune artiste
qui habite à jouer en josas coin de ce
mélange hip hop reggae avec des
sonorités gospel quand j'ai fait des
mixtapes et là c'est vraiment l'album
concret qu'a fait que voilà je suis
arrivé jusqu'à jusqu'à là aujourd'hui
donc surtout sur des instrus phase 1
parce que sur les mixtapes c'était des
faces b donc des instructive appartenait
pas donc là c'est vraiment un produit
que j'ai faits de a à z flocons dans cet
album intitulé ma galaxy ce sont 13
titres qui parlent de la vie quotidienne
d'amour ou encore de problèmes de
société son dernier clip mon étoile est
sorti le même jour que son album le 8
avril dernier
[Musique]
je me suis mis dans ma bulle pour
raconter un peu ce que je voyais les
ressentis des gens de ce que ce qui me
disaient entre guillemets et je le
retranscris sur ce morceau autre clip
qui rassemble plus de 11000 vu kim t'nb
il a été tourné à fontenay-le-fleury le
clip on l'a tourné à fontaine fleurie
aux copains d'abord et c'est marrant
parce qu'en plus il y avait un concept
vu que là bas il y avait un coiffeur il
y avait un tatoueur mines salle une
grande salle terrain c'est tout donc on
a joué un peu de tout ça parce qu'à la
base c'est un restaurant qui a plusieurs
concepts et donc avec les dix artistes
en fait tout le monde avait son rôle à
jouer c'était plutôt sympa on se fera
une petite tournée dans la france et en
belgique prochaine date le 7 mai à paris
il s'arrêtera aussi au bar-restaurant
copains d'abord à fontenay le fleury